-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show,"
ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, after
seven months of negotiations,
late Friday night,
the House finally passed
President Biden's
infrastructure deal.
Yeah. So that's
obviously -- Yeah.
So, obviously --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's probably what everyone
was talking about this weekend.
-Big Bird is causing a stir.
-Big bird announced he was
getting vaccinated
against COVID.
-Big Bird got his COVID shot
over the weekend.
-Big Bird announces
he's been vaccinated.
-Big Bird got the jab.
-Somehow, that was
the big story this weekend --
Big Bird tweeting
that he got vaccinated.
Yep.
It was a big day,
actually, for Big Bird,
because immediately
after getting vaccinated,
he was signed by
the Green Bay Packers.
So that is amazing.
That's amazing to see
that career.
Some more COVID news.
Today, the U.S.
lifted the travel ban on
vaccinated tourists
for more than 30 countries.
Of course, all the airports
are going to be slammed.
Flight attendants were like,
"We're going to need
more duct tape."
That's right -- travelers are
thrilled to be back.
It's the first time people
ever cried tears of joy
at the sight of LaGuardia.
That's right -- New York City is
expecting tens of thousands
of tourists, and they're all
going to walk in front of you.
"Oh, wow."
19 months for a travel ban
is a long time.
Yep, your friend who left to
study abroad in January 2020
actually came back
speaking fluent Italian.
-Oh!
-Well, as I mentioned,
on Friday night,
the House passed Biden's
infrastructure bill.
The bill took forever to pass.
When it was over,
they wrapped Biden in
a foil marathon blanket
and gave him a medal.
They go...
Yeah, only 13 House Republicans
voted for the bill,
while the rest said,
"We think that
if you're driving over
a collapsed bridge,
you can just speed up
and you'll probably make it."
"You guys ever seen
the documentary
'Fast and the Furious?'"
Some business news.
Walmart just announced
that it is now using
fully driverless trucks to
deliver groceries to customers.
-Ooh.
-It's pretty cool, actually.
The driverless trucks
will pick up items from Walmart
and then deliver them right
through your living-room wall.
What?!
-Oh, yeah!
-Yeah.
Walmart is the only place you'll
find cutting-edge technology
and also a barefoot guy
buying margarita mix.
"I'm surprised
it's not more packed here
at 3:00 in the morning."
Hey, I saw that,
guys, restaurants
are facing a shortage because of
supply-chain issues
of takeout containers.
-Ooh!
-Yeah, that will be fun when
the Uber Eats guy is like,
"Here's your fries.
Put it on your lap
or you want it..."
But this is
a huge problem for McDonald's,
because they actually make
McRibs out of
takeout containers.
-Really?
-That's what I heard.
That's what I heard.
I don't know.
Hey, I saw that,
in a recent Instagram post,
Vin Diesel called Dwayne Johnson
his "little brother"
and asked him to return to
the "Fast & Furious" franchise.
Yeah. It turns out Vin Diesel
also left a voicemail
to follow up with him, and we
actually got our hands on it.
-Oh, my gosh!
-You guys want to hear it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, this is an exclusive.
Let's take a listen. Vin Diesel.
[ Beep ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We got the exclusive.
We got it tonight.
Wow.
And, finally, the New York City
Marathon was this weekend.
Congrats to anyone who raced it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Amazing.
I read that one guy ran 17 miles
with an engagement ring
and then proposed to his
girlfriend during the race.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
What's more romantic
than proposing
next to Times Square Elmo
peeing his costume?
You know, that's...
It actually was very cute.
They even celebrated with
tiny paper cups
filled with champagne.
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody!
-♪ I'm live,
design a finer rhyme ♪
♪ That's right on time ♪
♪ I'm a step beyond
and not behind the line ♪
♪ That separates thought
from divine ♪
♪ Better take it as
a caution or a warning sign ♪
♪ Antonyms,
words I'm sending 'em ♪
♪ Homonyms, synonyms
good like M&M'S ♪
♪ Yeah, Questlove
starts slicin' ♪
♪ I turn a mic's name to Tyson ♪
-Oh! It is Monday.
We are very excited to be back.
We have a great week
of shows ahead.
Will Smith will be here.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Will Ferrell
will be stopping by.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And, on Thursday,
we've got a very special show.
In honor of Veterans Day,
our entire audience
will be made up of
veterans and their families.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And that's Thursday.
And our guest will be
the one-and-only Taylor Swift.
That is this Thursday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You don't want to miss it
this Thursday,
but What a show
we have for you tonight.
His stand-up special,
"Shame the Devil,"
premieres next week on Netflix.
Michael Che is here.
-Come on!
-"Shame the Devil."
Michael Che.
Plus, gosh, we love this guy.
He's got the number-1 album
in the U.S. and U.K.
right now with "=".
Ed Sheeran
is on the show tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Plus, she's the greatest.
Just launched her brand-new
website called Martha.com.
Always welcome here.
Gosh, I love her so much.
Martha Stewart is on the show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just quality.
And speaking of
crushing it right now,
we have music from
Summer Walker!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
-Wow!
-She is crushing it right now.
Guys, did you ever see
a photo in the news
and think the headline could
be much better?
Well, I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"News & Improved."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ "News & Improved" ♪
-For example,
check out this first photo.
The original headline was...
The headline
can definitely be improved,
because if you only
look at the photo,
the headline could have been...
Uh...May 6th.
-No.
-May 7th.
-May 8th?
-No.
-Is it in May?
-Check out
this -- Is your name May?
-No.
-Have you ever met anyone
named May?
-No. Well, once.
-Good night, everybody.
Check out this next photo.
The original headline was...
If you only looked at the photo,
the headline could've been...
"Don't --
Mama needs her Franzia!"
The next headline was...
But the headline
could have been...
It's like...
"I'll be wearing
a bright-orange blazer."
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
-Wow!
-That's terrible.
-ABBA?
-Mamma mia!
-Yeah. Up next,
this headline says...
Headline could have been...
[ Chuckles ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
The shower?
Drinking in the shower?
-Six shower beers? Wow!
-Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
Oh, yeah.
"Freaking out!"
Finally, this headline was...
Headline could have been...
That is all the time we have for
"News & Improved"!